We're going to talk
about propositions
and logical operations
in this little clip,
and let's begin then with a
discussion of propositions.
So to a mathematician and,
in particular in this class,
we're going to use
the word proposition
to refer to something that
is either true or false.
An example would be there
are five regular solids.
This happens to be true.
In some terms we even prove it.
It implies, for example, that if
you wanted to place, let's say,
100 fixed-position
satellites around the earth
in a uniform way,
you can't do it
because there isn't any
100 vertex regular solid.
The biggest one is 20 vertices.
OK.
Well, if I change it
to six, guess what?
The assertion there are six
regular solids is false.
So that's a
simple-minded example
of two well-defined
propositions, one of which
is true, one of which is false.
Propositions don't
have to be true always.
What are some non-examples?
Well, wake up is
not a proposition,
because it's an imperative.
It's not true or false, and
where am I is a question.
It's not true or false.
And it's 3:00 PM is
not a proposition,
because it's true or
false at any given moment,
but whether or not it's true
or false depends on the time,
and that's a complication
we don't want to get into.
The idea is, a proposition is
some fixed assertion that's
either true forever
or not true forever.
Now, one of the reasons
why mathematicians bring up
this abstraction of propositions
and the operations on them
that we're about to see is
that ordinary language tends
to be ambiguous and that, of
course, will cause problems
in mathematical reasoning
just as it would in a program.
One of the most ambiguous
of the phrases in English
that connects
propositions is Or.
So let's look at this example.
Greeks carry swords or javelins,
and if I was transcribing this
into precise math
notation, I could
say G for Greeks implies S
for swords or J for javelin,
so this is an assertion
that if you're Greek, then
you carry a sword or a javelin.
Greeks implies sword or javelin.
Really, I should
say Greek soldiers,
but let that be implicit.
That's how we're going to
translate this sentence
into just using these operators
to paraphrase what's going on.
The problem is,
what does Or mean?
And it turns out that
for javelins and swords
it's true even if
a Greek carries
both a sword and a javelin.
This is an inclusive Or.
A Greek soldier would carry
both a sword and a javelin
because, in fact, a javelin is
a good long-distance weapon,
and a sword is good for
defending yourself close in,
and you certainly want to have
both, especially after you've
thrown your javelin,
and you don't have
anything left but the sword.
Now, there's many
standard notations
for these logical
connectives that build up
larger propositions out
of component propositions,
so one of the things is this V
symbol, or disjunction symbol,
is used by logicians
often instead of Or,
and this arrow means
implies or sometimes
a double bar arrow
also means implies,
but we're not going
to get into that.
I'm not going ask you to
memorize these symbols.
We'll just stick to the
words which don't take up
that much more room.
Let's look at another example.
Greeks carry bronze
or copper swords.
Syntactically this
has the same structure
as the previous
phrase, but we're
going to translate
it differently,
and the reason is
that we mean here
that a Greek soldier is not
going to carry both a bronze
and copper sword.
Why is that?
Well, bronze swords are just
way better than copper swords.
They'll slice right
through copper.
They're much
harder, and it's not
worth the weight to carry this
inferior copper sword when
you have a much better one.
So this time we mean the
Greeks carry exactly one
of a bronze or a copper sword.
You'd carry a copper sword
if you didn't have access
to a bronze one.
And so now we translate
that into Greek implies
B for bronze or C for copper,
but this time we use the X Or.
X Or means that one of
them is true exactly
but not both and not neither.
Again, there's this plus
sign notation for X Or,
because as we'll see it acts a
little bit like adding numbers
by 2 where 1 plus 1 is 0.
So let's be more precise about
the two definitions of Or and X
Or and how they work,
and the assertion is
that if I think of P and Q as
placeholders for propositions
that are either true or false,
then the composite proposition
P or Q is true if, and only
if, P is true or Q is true
or both are true,
and I could express
this assertion in English
this, if and only if,
by giving you a so-called
truth table, where
in these two columns
or all these rows
I've enumerated all the possible
pairs of values of P and Q.
So P and Q might
both be true, that P
might be true and Q false, P
false, Q true, and both of them
are false.
And for each of those possible
combinations of the truth
values of Q and P, I tell you
the truth value of P or Q,
and the notable thing is this
last row where I'm telling you
that the only way
that P or Q is false
is if both P and Q are false.
For X Or, as we
said, the P or X Or Q
is true if, and only if,
exactly one of P and Q is true,
so if I was expressing
that as a truth table,
we'd see that where there's TT
is false, and where there's FF
it's false, because it's not
the case in either of those
two rows that
exactly one is true,
but the middle row is
exactly one is true.
And so P X or Q is true.
So this truth table
is just a precise way
of defining how X Or
acts on truth values.
There's another connective,
And, which works even more
straightforwardly.
The value of P and Q is
true if, and only if,
both P and Q are true, and
there's this truth table.
Again, the salient row is that
it's true only if, and only
if, both P and Q are true.
Another crucial
logical operation
is the negation
operation, or Not.
So Not P just flips the truth
value of P. If P is true,
then not P is false.
If not P is true,
then P is false,
and there it's very
trivial truth table,
trivial because there's only two
values to be concerned about.
When P is true, not P is false.
When P is false, not P is true.
One of the places that
this notion of combining
basic propositions to
using logical operations
to build up more complicated
composite proposition
is in programming.
Here's a typical kind of
phrase that comes from Java.
Java uses this
double vertical bar
to mean Or,
inclusive by the way,
and double ampersand
to mean And, so in Java
this is a piece of
legitimate Java code
that's doing a test to
evaluate this expression, if X
is greater than 0 or X is
less than or equal to 0
and Y is greater than 100,
then if that test comes out
to be true, then you
do a bunch of code
that follows the test up to
some delimiter that tells you
where to stop.
And if it's false, you just
skip all that stuff and go on.
So we use sort of
Boolean expressions
or logical expressions like this
in a very standard way in most
programming languages.
The other place where
these operations come up
is in digital logic, and the
digital circuit designers
have their own notation,
which I'll just mention,
but we're not, again, impose
on you but you should be aware.
One notation they use that
we'll use as well because it's
so economical is that
not X can be abbreviated
by writing a bar over the X.
More generally, not a
complicated expression
can be abbreviated
by writing a bar
over the complicated expression.
I just saved some
space, and so we'll
use it, but not the following.
In digital logic, the
idea is that you're
talking about circuits where the
only distinction of the signal
that's coming in
electrically is whether it's
a high voltage or a low voltage,
with high voltage is denoted
by 1, and low
voltage denoted by 0,
and the way that
digital logic behaves
is that the 1 corresponds
to true at the 0 corresponds
to false.
Then the And operation is simply
multiplication, because the 1
or 0 times 1 or 0 is 1
only when both of them
are 1 for ordinary
multiplication, which
is exactly the way And behaves
when 1 means true and 0
means false.
Unfortunately, the
digital designers
use Plus when they mean Or.
They do not mean
that 1 plus 1 is 2.
They mean that 1 plus 1
is 1, and just a thing
to watch out four.
That's part of the reason we're
not going to use this notation.
Let's just stick to our
ordinary word notation
that we give on the right.